hello i'm karen gillan and we are doing
the wired autocomplete interview here we
go
[Music]
like what's going on out there am i on
that feet fetish thing those are the
types of things i want to know
what does karen gillen
sound like like this like a scottish
person that's maybe been on holiday in
america it's very rare that i'm acting
in my natural accent and honestly it's
gotten to the point now where i'm more
comfortable acting in a different accent
i'm really comfortable in an american
accent and sometimes i'll even use it to
like a spam caller and i like to keep
them on the phone for as long as
possible i'll be american on those calls
as well
what character does karen gillen
play in he's not finished
avengers
my character is nebula she is a bald
blue
alien who started in guardians of the
galaxy vol 1. and she is a daughter of
thanos the worst guy ever
and sisters with gamora and she's one of
my favorite characters that i've ever
played actually she's kind of like this
scapegoated sibling and a terrible toxic
family dynamic and all the stuff i love
to play what
or is this all one thing i guess we'll
find out
what racist nebula and guardians of the
galaxy i i don't know i thought she was
cree and then someone corrected me and
said part luthemoid do i know what a
loophomoid is
no i don't what
if karen gillan what if karen gillan
did what i don't know what does it mean
who would ask this type of question
leaving us all hanging like this
okay
when did karen gillen join doctor who i
was 21 years old so a baby that was the
big break of my career i went from not
working very much as an actor to being
in a very beloved show in the uk and i
miss it so much actually will karen
gillen return to doctor who never say
never if i was asked i would be really
really interested in keen oh it would be
really amazing i would like to do it
with matt smith and arthur darvill if i
was going to go back who was karen
gillan in call of the wild i played the
dog no i didn't so i played a character
called mercedes she was like a
drunk woman
trying to get some gold and she wasn't
very nice that's probably why she's not
in the movie very much it felt like
every time i have been drunk actually
was just now research who was karen
gillan
stunt double in jumanji okay so my stunt
double was called janelle curfman and
she is an incredible stunt woman we call
her the real ruby roundhouse because
she's the one that's actually doing
round houses okay i'll tell you the
truth you know what we do i will just
turn around and i won't even lift my leg
and then they will cgi my legging
it's incredible so yeah she makes me
look really good so thanks janelle
thank you
is karen gillan a karen
no no i am not that type of karen i
think this is going to be the death of
the name karen i think we're going to be
extinct
maybe it's for the best okay is karen
gillen a model
don't mind this question
no i'm not
i'm not i'm an actress when i first
moved to london i went to drama school
and then i dropped out of drama school
because i got one acting role and then i
just didn't have any acting work after
that and then someone said oh you could
do modeling because you're a giant it
was more like graduate fashion week
where it would be like fashion students
doing really weird things with armholes
and weird places and then i'd walk down
the catwalk
is karen gillan and harry potter no i do
get confused with ron weasley a lot
though
but no that's not me
is karen gillan
in game of thrones no
i'm not in game of thrones i actually
remember i auditioned for game of
thrones and then got doctor who like
right after that a few people have come
up to me and said that i look like
sophie turner which is a massive
compliment and i'll take it but there
was one guy that was like oh my god i've
just realized where i know you're from
it's those electric blue eyes that gave
you away sophie turner and like he was
looking at me and i don't even have blue
eyes just wanted it to be sophie turner
okay
is karen gillan in star wars rise of
skywalker
no why why do you think this i'm sorry i
i wish i was this is just reminding me
of all the things i don't have parts in
what are the things i do have parts
i'm scared of the statements people make
about me okay karen gillan how tall
okay this is this is a question
disguised as a statement 5 foot 11.
weirdly tall karen gillen batgirl i'm
not bad girl it's another roll that i
don't have thank you karen gillen
gunpowder milkshake jacket that jacket
is really cool the one that i wear in
gunpowder milkshake it's orange it's a
bomber jacket kind of like um ryan
gosling's jacket and drive and i have
the jacket i own it it's mine and it's
in my wardrobe karen gillan van gogh i'm
in a room full of americans who are like
it's van gogh
but in britain we say van gogh that's
what we say i know why this is here it's
because there was an episode of doctor
who where we meet van gogh and people
love it
including me
karen gillan funny this is just a true
statement this is just a fact karen
gillan the party's just beginning okay
so the party's just beginning is a film
that i wrote and directed it was a lot
to beat in something while directing it
next time maybe i'll just be behind the
camera next card thank you
oh no can karen gillen sing i used to
sing a lot actually when i was younger a
lot of musical theater but i don't
really do it as much as i used to it
used to be like one of my main things
and now it's just something that happens
in the shower can garen gillen fight
well yeah i mean i i don't know it's
never been put to the test in like real
life i've done a lot of action sequences
now so i've definitely gotten better i
like to think oh you would pull out all
the moves that you've been taught on the
films like get them into this hole and
this thing
but the sad reality is probably i'm a
possum can karen gillen
swim i can sort of swim like if i was in
the ocean i would definitely die like i
can get from one side of the pool to the
other this has come up a few times so
many times actually that my friend wrote
a song called karen can swim
and she wraps on it
does karen gillen drive ah what is all
the transportation no i don't drive i'm
a woman in my 30s and i can't transport
myself on water or on roads does karen
gillen have siblings no i'm an only
child i think it would be fun to have
siblings but i don't have any and that's
also fun because i got so much attention
growing up rapid fire rapid fire let's
go how did karen gillan this is really
glued on become famous i think that i
became more known when i got the part in
doctor who that was my big break and i
went from not to a hundred in the space
of an hour of that news being released
and it was a wild ride read
i did an audition and uh got a call back
had to read with james gunn the director
and then do a screen test where they
made me bold and blue and then burst out
crying during the screen test but it was
fine because it made sense in the
context of the scene and then they gave
me the part
was karen gillan in a soap opera no
wish i was though love a good soap where
is karen gillan now i'm here with wired
um reading this out it's good to be here
now this is this is good i feel like
i've landed in a good spot what did you
learn about yourself today i am a tall
person who
really needs to learn how to drive
because this is just getting
embarrassing at this point it's being
googled by people